it was very tough on my marriage and my
relationship with the kids
that have caused enough pain for my
family
I'm gonna have to live with it the rest
of my life Arnold Schwarzenegger ready
to get candid about his past mistakes
people will remember my successes and
they were also remember those failures
the only thing that no one can take from
you is your mind it's all part of the
movie icon's new docu-series Arnold
I sold myself on that stage
thousands of people screaming
in the three-part docu-series dropping
June 7th on Netflix the bodybuilder
turned Action Hero opens up
there was a lot of things they had to
learn
that they had to overcome ET was along
for the ride on Arnold's One of a Kind
Journey
including his pivot from Hollywood to
the governor's mansion I was looking for
another challenge politics
that's good to work he blew up the
political system
problems and problems but I want to do
the things that everyone calls
impossible
I think it's great that all these people
come out and take time out of their day
and you know come out here to cheer
Arnold on of course when Arnold left
office in 2011
it coincided with the downfall of his
25-year marriage to Maria Shriver there
have caused enough pain for my family
he admitted to following a secret son
with a longtime employee of their
household staff I'm gonna have to live
with it the rest of my life Arnold and
Maria immediately separated but their
divorce wasn't finalized until two years
ago we get along really well and yet
they've remained friendly exes while
co-parenting their four children it was
very tough on my marriage on my
relationship with the kids no matter
what it takes Rook your ass off
do it
do it now it's really in the end the
most important thing is that the kids
are doing well and the Maria always has
been an extraordinary mother and always
has worked with the kids very closely I
was always more off working and being on
location and she was doing the work and
so together we always were a good team
in that this is the guy who turns his
boat towards the torpedo
you're always hungry you're never really
satisfied well Arnold seems very
satisfied with the in-depth look at the
good and the bad telling fans don't miss
it why did you give up
well because my vision didn't talk about
giving up my vision was climbing that
mountain
foreign